sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder den des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit
oder ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern wäldern
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
hitler viele der sowjetunion bis zur
sogenannten aaa linie vorstoßen
die arminia streckte sich von
archangelsk am eismeer bis nach
astrachan am kaspischen meer wer sich
westlich dieser linie befand wurde
versklavt oder getötet
im frühling 1942 will hitler die
offensive fortsetzen die von moskau zum
erliegen gekommen war er will bis zur
linie vorstoßen bis in den kaukasus und
bis nach stalingrad
[Musik]
im frühjahr 1942 kontrollieren die
achsenmächte mehr als ein drittel der
weltbevölkerung und der bodenschätze auf
der erde
doch das blatt beginnt sich zu wenden
die nortel turm das jahr 1942 zu
verstehen ist es wichtig festzuhalten
dass die deutschen die sowjets 1941
nicht besiegen konnten
im märz 1942 sind 51 deutsche divisionen
in westeuropa stationiert
167 kämpfen an der ostfront hinzu kommen
weitere truppen der achsenmächte und
ihrer verbündeten ende juni 1942 schickt
hitler sie in die nächste schlacht code
name unternehmen blau
doch wie will man 1942 erfolgreich sein
wo man schon 1941 mit mehr ressourcen
scheiterte hitler geht das problem
ökonomisch an er startet unternehmen
blau so der name der sommeroffensive
1942 um sich kriegswichtige bodenschätze
wie öl im süden russlands zu sichern
italien hatte unternehmen barbarossa
1941 mit 62.000 soldaten unterstützt als
unternehmen blau startet erhöht
mussolini seine truppen auf 230.000 sie
positionieren sich zwischen der zweiten
ungarischen und der dritten rumänischen
armee damit ein bestehender zwist beider
nationen nicht eskaliert
generalfeldmarschall feder von bock soll
die offensive der heeresgruppe süd
anführen um den kaukasus mit seinen
ergiebigen ölquellen zu erobern
distance ist dem unternehmen blau
mussten die truppen eine distanz von 500
kilometern zurücklegen von der ost
ukraine bis nach stalingrad
bei stalingrad ist nur das tor zum
kaukasus von dort sind es noch mal 300
kilometer bis in den kaukasus
[Musik]
im frühjahr 1942 hat die elfte armee der
wehrmacht bereits weite teile der krim
besetzt
am 12 mai startet die rote armee unter
marshalls simeon timoshenko südlich von
prag auf eine gegenoffensive
ziel ist die ein schließung der sechsten
deutschen armee unter general friedrich
paulus doch es kommt anders
der russische präventivschlag mündete in
einer katastrophe
paulus sechster armee sowie
panzerverbände der armee gruppe von
kleist kesseln die rotarmisten ein
240.000 sowjetsoldaten werden gefangen
genommen etwa
1250 panzer und mehr als 2000 geschütze
zerstört oder erbeutet die deutsche
offensive nimmt fahrt auf
im zweiten jahr des ost feldzugs fehlten
den deutschen die ressourcen für eine
komplette front offensive also entschied
man sich für eine sommeroffensive im
süden
deutsche und ungarische truppen starten
zunächst eine offensive östlich von
kursk
am 6 juli erobern sie
wochentag darauf beginnt die zweite
phase der deutschen offensive
das ziel rostov am don
nachdem die rote armee im süden
zerschlagen wird befiehlt hitler am 23
juli die heeresgruppe süd aufzuteilen
generalstabschef franz halder nennt die
entscheidung in seinem tagebuch
haarsträubend und gefährlich
stellen eine der eigenschaften die
hitler zu einem erfolgreichen anführer
machte war sein unerschütterlicher
glaube an sich selbst den stets
begleitete
usb-stecker menschen die sich alles
selbst beibringen haben immer etwas
beängstigendes autodidakten mit
wahnhaften ideen mir auch mussolini oder
stalin extrem gefährlich
us-dollar notiert auch
die immer schon vorhandene
unterschätzung der feindlichen
möglichkeiten nimmt allmählich groteske
formen an
hollywood die eine hälfte der truppen
sollte zu den ölfeldern im kaukasus im
süden des landes marschieren um
russlands industrie lahmzulegen und die
treibstoffversorgung zu kappen
[Musik]
am 16 juli sucht hitler das
führerhauptquartier werwolf auf seine
neue kommandozentrale in der west
ukraine
von hier aus wird der kaukasus vorstoß
decknamen operation edelweiß organisiert
die heeresgruppe a soll entlang der
schwarzmeerküste bis zu den erdöl
städten mike ob grosny und baku
vorstoßen
in zwölf tagen legt sie über 550
kilometer zurück
[Musik]
die heeresgruppe b soll im rahmen von
operation fischreiher nach stalingrad
ziehen
die wolga stadt ihren wichtigen hafen
mittlerweile wohl vertraut
stammtisch der stolz die jungen russen
es ist ihre stadt erbaut während
überzeugt
am 9 august besetzt von kleist erste
panzerarmee die ölfelder bei mike ob
am 21 august überquert die sechste armee
den donner und beginnt mit ihrem
vormarsch auf stalingrad
[Applaus]
als die deutschen panzer vorrücken
bringt die rote armee ihre flak
geschütze in stellung
viele werden von jungen frauen und
abiturientinnen bedient kaum eine von
ihnen wird überleben
rund eine million frauen dienten in der
roten armee
490.000 von ihnen kämpfen an der front
allein 2500 erhalten eine scharfschützen
ausbildung sie sind den männlichen
soldaten formal gleichgestellt nur dass
sie 100 gramm mehr seife erhalten
die deutschen werfen an einem tag mehr
als 1000 tonnen bomben über der stadt ab
damals lebten hier 400.000 menschen und
allein in der ersten woche starben
40.000
stalins befehl nummer 227 lautet
schlicht nicht einen schritt zurück
und weiter
miesmacher und feiglinge müssen auf der
stelle vernichtet werden
[Musik]
domains über der westen verweist immer
wieder auf das totalitäre regime dass
alle angst hatten dass hinter jedem ein
bewaffneter soldat steht aber das stimmt
nicht es ist schlicht unmöglich dass so
viele auf ihrer eigenen mitbürger
schließen
in der schlacht um stalingrad werden
13.000 rotarmisten exekutiert wegen
fahnenflucht oder feigheit vor dem feind
bevor sie erschossen werden müssen sie
ihre uniform ablegen denn die müssen
wieder verwendet werden und sollten
möglichst keine einschusslöcher
aufweisen
die kubi stalins personalpolitik und
sein regierungsstil waren vor allem
eines gnadenlosen
stalin macht auch zugeständnisse wenn es
ihm nützt einige kirchen werden wieder
eröffnet und erstmals seit der
revolution werden offiziere wieder mit
ihrem dienstgrad angesprochen aus
großbritannien lässt sich die ods sr
einen großen posten gold dessen liefern
dabei geht es laut stalin nicht nur um
die auszeichnung sondern um ordnung und
disziplin
je länger der krieg dauerte desto mehr
entscheidungsspielraum ließ stalin
seiner militärischen führung kittler
macht er das gegenteil
am 23 august erreicht eine voraus
abteilung der 16 panzerdivision den
nördlichsten vorort von stalingrad als
die deutschen soldaten auf einer
einrichtung für geistig behinderte
kinder stoßen erschießen sie sämtliche
insassen
sie sind zwischen zehn und 14 jahre alt
zug will ganz offensichtlich war das
motto der deutschen dass in dieser
schlacht keine tabus mehr geld
am 27 august keinen stalin den 46
jährigen schumacher sohn general georgi
schukow zum stellvertretenden
oberbefehlshaber der roten armee sein
auftrag die verteidigung stalingrad
der soldat lefkas ihr witz stand unter
seinem kommando
wir fuhren mit dem zug bis nach
kann weiter ging es nicht weil die
gleise völlig zerstört waren gesprungen
die restlichen 100 kilometer bis nach
stalingrad mussten wir laufen
das war im august 1942
wir marschierten nur nachts weil die
deutschen tagsüber alles bombardierten
was sich bewegt
[Applaus]
am 2 september notiert general halder
nach einer lagebesprechung mit hitler
das beim eindringen in die stadt die
gesamte männliche bevölkerung beseitigt
werden soll das stalingrad mit seiner
eine million zählenden durchweg
kommunistischen einwohnerschaft
besonders gefährlich seien
die weibliche bevölkerung wiederum solle
man abtransportieren wohin sagt er nicht
der duisburger schriftsteller willy
peter reese ist an der ostfront
stationiert zweimal wird er verwundet
gehe er 1944 in weißrussland feld
1942 schreibt er die juden ermordet als
brüllende horde nach russland marschiert
die menschen geknebelt im blute gesäbelt
vom kleine geführt sind wir die
gesandten des albers bekannten und
warten in blut
[Musik]
am zwölften september bestellt hitler
friedrich paulus in das
führerhauptquartier werwolf nah wie nie
zahlen und verlangt die einnahme
stalingrad
am 13 september beginnt der angriff auf
die innenstadt
am 14 september wird der hauptbahnhof
fünf mal erobert und wieder
zurückerobert
auch in den folgenden tagen bleibt der
bereich um den hauptbahnhof hart
umkämpft
als paar große teile der sechsten armee
und der vierten panzerarmee befanden
sich in stalingrad die russen leisteten
erbitterten widerstand
anfang oktober bereiten die deutschen
einen großangriff auf das traktorenwerk
zwischen ski vor am 14 oktober ist es
soweit
300 sturz kampfbomber unterstützen den
infanterie angriff der wehrmacht ein
deutscher offizier beschreibt den kampf
es war ein zermürbender kampf auf und
unter der erde in den trümmern kellern
und kanälen
eine erbitterte gnadenlose schlacht
beginnt um jedes stockwerk um jeden raum
die deutschen sprechen vom ratten krieg
stalingrad liegt in trümmern doch die
stadt hält sich an die durchhalte befehl
klar seine ganze streitmacht wieder
konzentriert und
im ersten stock musste der größte fehler
der deutschen war es panzer und so viele
truppen in die stadt zu verlegen man
musste zwar auf die russische defensiv
aktion reagieren aber es war die falsche
strategie truppen in die stadt zu
schicken
die hard to match the mood der
rotarmisten war herausragend doch leider
zählte der einzelne soldat in der
sowjetunion nicht viel
wahrscheinlich dachte man dass die
vielen frauen im riesigen russland
ohnehin genügend soldaten gebären und
ob die ihnen überleben oder nicht war
für die offiziere sekundär sie schickten
sie einfach ins gemetzel
allein zwischen dem 13 und 17 oktober
sterben rund 12.000 rotarmisten in der
schlacht ums traktorenwerk
hitler ist überzeugt dass die rote armee
schon bald einknicken wird
german die deutschen wollten die stadt
komplett auslöschen doch dabei entstehen
trümmer und wie sich bereits mehrfach
während des zweiten weltkriegs zeigte
sind die häufig ein problem für die
angreifer vor allem wenn man auf panzer
und mauern als schutz vertraut
[Musik]
am 8 november auf dem höhepunkt der
schlacht um stalingrad hält hitler eine
rede im münchner löwenbräukeller
er sagt
ich sehe gerade heute mit einer großen
zuversicht in die zukunft
[Musik]
doch dazu hat er wenig grund
es war erreichen deutsche truppen am 11
november endlich das ufer der wolga doch
auf der anderen flussseite stehen eine
millionen rotarmisten in reserve dazu
979 panzer
14.000 geschütze und
1350 flugzeuge
tagsüber hielten wir uns versteckt
schließlich handelte sich um eine
militärische geheimoperationen die
deutschen ahnten nichts davon sie
merkten auch nicht dass der moment nahte
an dem wir die deutsche armee
vollständig umzingeln würden
mit der offensive am 19 november 1943
ging es dann los
die disziplin stalingrad herrschten
minus 50 grad
es war ein so kalter winter im dezember
und januar dass man sich kaum bewegen
konnte
moscheen haben wir ließen die motoren
der panzer laufen weil sie wärme
produziert
und verdammten uns auf diese weise neben
den auspuffrohren auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am morgen des 19 november den russland
noch heute als tag der artillerie feiert
starten die sowjets eine große
gegenoffensive
[Musik]
13.500 41 artillerie geschütze feuern
aus allen rohren es ist der beginn von
operation uranus
unserer artillerie machte sich bereit
und dann nahmen wir die deutschen
stellungen 30 minuten lang unter feuer
ohne unterbrechung
die katjuscha genannten raketen davor
feuerten salven ab sie waren lauter als
alles was wir jemals gehört hatten
[Applaus]
optimal ist die jubelten einige weinten
vor glück endlich nun werden wir doch
nicht verlieren verstehen sie
[Musik]
wir rückten weiter vor immer weiter
innerhalb von 24 stunden geraten 65.000
rumänische soldaten in gefangenschaft
die russen nutzten eine schwachstelle in
der deutschen verteidigungslinie aus und
zwar die verbündeten ungarischen und
rumänischen truppen die die sechste
armee verstärkten
am 20 november eröffnet die rote armee
südlich von stalingrad eine weitere
front ziel ist eine einkesselung der
deutschen truppen am
21 november empfiehlt paulus den rückzug
zum don doch hitlers befehl ist
eindeutig durchhalten um jeden preis
die sechste armee rund 250.000 soldaten
sowie 30.000 verbündete truppen werden
auf einer fläche von 40 mal 50
kilometern eingekesselt
am 22 november sind die truppen komplett
eingeschlossen
paulus bittet um erlaubnis zum ausbruch
doch hitler lehnt ab daraufhin befiehlt
paulus sollen wir jetzt den widerstand
aufgeben unter keinen umständen wir
müssen um jeden fußbreit boden kämpfen
und dem großen schaden zufügen wo wir
können halt aus die eingekesselten üben
sich in zweckoptimismus
unter den soldaten macht ein vers die
runde
drum haltet aus der führer hat euch raus
live weekend das leben in stalingrad
wurde zunehmend schwierig sie haben so
viele deutsche soldaten starben und
nicht nur im kampf sondern auch wegen
der extremen kälte und der schlechten
versorgung mit lebensmitteln
es sei eine tortur
[Musik]
am zwölften dezember starten die
deutschen das unternehmen winter
gewitter das ziel den ring um die
sechste armee aufzubrechen um die
eingekesselten truppen zu befreien doch
der kampf gegen die dreifach überlegene
rote armee ist aussichtslos auch die
achte italienische armee und die dritte
rumänische armee können den sowjets
nichts entgegensetzen sie werden
vernichtend geschlagen
kämpften für irland die italiener aber
kämpften für nichts sie wurden geholt
und den deutschen bei der eroberung
russlands zu helfen man hatte sie aus
ihren italienischen paradiesen in den
schnee getrieben für sie war es eine
tragödie
am 23 dezember einen tag vor weihnachten
wird unternehmen winter gewitter
abgebrochen
es war der vierten panzerarmee nicht
gelungen einen korridor für die noch 60
kilometer entfernte sechster armee zu
öffnen
und die aussicht auf erfolg war ohnehin
gering gewesen zum einen gab es nicht
genug funktionstüchtige
transportflugzeuge außerdem wollte
hitler der sechsten armee nicht die
erlaubnis für einen ausbruchsversuch
erteilen
der nachschub wird knapp
der mini de die armee brauchte jeden tag
700 tonnen nachschub karge minimum waren
500 tonnen die hälfte davon entfielen
auf lebensmittel darüber hinaus brauchte
man munition und weiteres material
tatsächlich kamen jedoch nur 85 tonnen
am 8 januar bietet general rogowski
paulus die ehrenvolle kapitulation an
doch hitler will davon nichts wissen
verbiete kapitulation die armee hält
ihre position bis zum letzten soldaten
und zur letzten patrone
paulus fügt sich hitlers willen und
lehnt das ultimatum ab
am nächsten tag erteilt rogowski den
befehl zum angriff
sie war klug und gut ausgebildet und
seine kriegsstrategie war effektiver
taxis
[Applaus]
am 10 januar 1943 staaten mehr als
200.000 rotarmisten und mehr als 250
panzer mit der operation kalsow zur
deutsche ring einen letzten angriff auf
den kessel am 22 meldet paulus über funk
truppe ohne munition und verpflegung
weitere verteidigung sinnlos
am 24 januar nimmt die rote armee das
letzte deutsche flugfeld ein und damit
auch die letzte hoffnung auf nachschub
die sechste armee ist besiegt goebbels
muss die hiobs botschaft unters volk
bringen er sagt
stalingrad war und ist der große
alarmruf des schicksals an die deutsche
nation ein volk das die stärke besitzt
ein solches unglück zu ertragen und auch
zu überwinden ist unbesiegbar
[Musik]
sie machten sie zu märtyrern um die
realität der verheerenden niederlage der
sechste armee zu verschleiern doch jedem
war klar dass dies ein wendepunkt war
nach dem ständigen höllenlärm der
geschütze der granaten und der bomben
herrschte jetzt überall stille
[Musik]
die schlacht war geschlagen die waffen
routen es herrschte absolute stille ein
ungewohnter zustand
[Musik]
ende januar 1943 befördert hitler paulus
zum generalfeldmarschall er hofft dass
dieser statt sich zu ergeben den
verklausulierten hinweis versteht und
den heldenhaften freitod wählt
doch paulus tut ihm diesen gefallen
nicht sondern kapituliert als hitler von
der gefangennahme seines
oberbefehlshabers erfährt tobt er der
mann hat sich tot zu schießen
doch paulus sieht das anders
[Musik]
wegen dieses böhmischen gefreiten
schieße ich mir doch keine kugel in den
kopf
[Musik]
stalingrad war die letzte schlacht die
auf augenhöhe geschlagen wurde danach
war das verhältnis 2 zu 1 gegen
deutschland das gleichgewicht der kräfte
dass man an der ostfront gebraucht hätte
gab es nicht mehr
[Musik]
was die anzahl der deutschen im
sowjetischer kriegsgefangenschaft
anbetrifft so differieren die zahl
91.000 98.000 101 1100 2001 mit
sicherheit weiß man nur dass 1955 als
die letzten soldaten der 6b wieder nach
deutschland zurückkehrten nicht einmal
mehr 6000 davon übrig waren
[Musik]
in gedenken an die gefallenen von
stalingrad spielt der deutschen reichs
rundfunk das adagio aus bruckners
siebter sinfonie
[Musik]
1945 wird es ein weiteres mal erklingen
nach der meldung von hitlers tod
[Musik]
auch nach der niederlage in stalingrad
kontrollieren die achsenmächte noch
immer teile der sowjetunion mit ihren
millionen von einwohnern
das wird noch fast anderthalb jahre
dauern bis die invasoren vollends
vertrieb sind
stalingrad war ein grandioser sieg für
die rote armee doch noch standen die
deutschen truppen tief in der
sowjetunion
die vorstellung dass die rote armee sie
eines tages bis nach berlin zurück
drängen würde war damals noch ein ferner
traum
stalingrad ist nach stalingrad machten
immer mehr deutsche hitler persönlich
für den negativen kriegsverlauf
verantwortlich
sie nahmen nicht andere hochrangige
nazis in haftung oder die umstände sie
zeigten mit dem finger auf hitler als
urheber dieser katastrophe also of
desaster
doch nicht nur die vernichtende
niederlage im fernen stalingrad
untergräbt die moral der deutschen
es ist vor allem die zerstörung der
heimischen städte
hatte man zu kriegsbeginn auch die
hoffnung dass die bombardements strikten
regeln folgen würden so änderte sich das
spätestens am 24
august 1940 als deutsche flugzeuge
anstatt flugzeug fabriken irrtümlich die
britische hauptstadt bombardiert
es sind die ersten bomben die auf london
fallen
winston churchill ist überzeugt dass es
sich um einen geplanten angriff handelt
und befiehlt einen vergeltungsschlag auf
berlin
harris leitet den angriff
winstons haltung war bombardieren was
das zeug hält
george l wünschte sich
einen absolut verheerenden vernichtenden
angriff mit schweren bomben auf die
heimat der nazis
studies tann studien des britischen
militärs und des innenministeriums kamen
zu dem schluss dass die gesellschaft
zusammenbrechen und die menschen in
panik geraten würden wenn ihre
wichtigsten zentren bombardiert werden
kritische berechnungen aus der
vorkriegszeit gehen davon aus dass pro
tonne abgeworfenen bomben mit 50 toten
und verletzten zu rechnen ist
bei späteren angriffen auf london dem
sogenannten blitz liegt die verlustrate
bei einem opfer pro tonne
viele experten gingen davon aus dass
flächenbombardements die art der
kriegsführung revolutionieren würden
doch zielgenaue bombardements auf
fabriken oder eisenbahnlinien sind zu
dieser zeit noch nicht möglich
es
entbehrt nicht einer gewissen ironie
dass england die deutschen luftangriffe
durch orchestrierte flugabwehr zurück
schlug dann aber so naiv zu glauben dass
man die deutsche industrie einfach so
kaputt bomben könnte
[Musik]
eine britische militär expertise über
die wirksamkeit von luftangriffen stellt
im sommer 1941 fest dass nur jeder
dritte bombe seine ladung innerhalb
eines ziel radius von acht kilometern
abwirft im mond losen nächten ist es nur
jeder fünfzehnte
dementsprechend passen die briten ihre
angriffsstrategien
definiert man eine ganze stadt als ziel
trifft man fast immer
es ist der beginn der flächen bomben aus
am 14 februar gibt das britische
luftfahrt ministerium den befehl zum
area bombing dem flächenbombardement für
harris genannt bomber harris ist mit der
umsetzung der maßnahme betraut er sagt
der krieg ist ein wettrennen dessen
preis der sieg ist das
ziel des flächenbombardements wird in
der area bombing der active klar
definiert die angriffe gelten der moral
der feindlichen zivilbevölkerung im
mittelpunkt denen die industriearbeiter
harris glaubt fest daran dass man
deutschland durch bomben terror in die
knie zwingen kann er spekuliert darauf
dass ein bonbon von industrieanlagen und
wohngebieten herr es spricht wenig
zimperlich von in tausend früher oder
später das kriegsende herbeiführen würde
für die deutsche bevölkerung gibt es
einen einfachen weg diesen herten zu
entkommen sie muss nur raus aus den
städten ihre arbeit ruhen lassen und
hinaus ausland gehen um das heimische
feuer aus der ferne betrachten zu können
[Musik]
1942 fließt ein drittel der britischen
militärausgaben in die finanzierung der
flächenbombardements ein weiteres
drittel wird für die produktion schwere
bombe ausgegeben
[Musik]
es stellte sich jedoch bald heraus dass
die alliierten bomben nur die
entschlossenheit der deutschen stärkten
deutschland bekommt doch zurück was ich
tun kann bereitet
für mich ist das nur schwer
nachvollziehen ich habe zahlreiche
berichte von deutschen gelesen die die
bombardements erlebt haben das ist ein
alptraum wie man ihn sich schlimmer kaum
vorstellen kann
die luftangriffe der alliierten treten
zunehmend den alltag der deutschen
insbesondere ab 1942 war die vor die
tuch seit dieser zeit nahm die zahl der
angriffe und die intensität der
bombardements zu windenergie umbringen
[Musik]
essen wird in der nacht vom achten auf
den neunten märz bombardiert am 28 und
29 märz greift die royal air force
lübeck an
234 maschine anwerfen mehr als 400
tonnen bomben über der hansestadt ab
lübeck rennt
320 menschen starben
1468 gebäude werden völlig zerstört
die prächtige mittelalterliche stadt
liegt in trümmern und
[Musik]
einige ziele wurden erst in letzter
minute ausgewählt an weihnachten
bombardierten wir eine kleine stadt in
der angeblichen munition gelagert wurde
es war eine schande
deutschlands antwort auf die zerstörung
sind die sogenannten baedeker angriffe
benannt nach dem gleichnamigen
reiseführer der bei der auswahl
historischer britischer städte zu rate
gezogen wird
harris dreht daraufhin weiter an der
eskalation schreibe 30 und 31 mai
schickt er erstmals mehr als 1000 bomber
gleichzeitig in die luft
[Musik]
das ziel seines angriffs ist köln seine
mission klar umrissen
das ziel die stadt köln zu zerstören
wenn wir erfolgreich sein wollen müssen
wir dem feind einen wirkungstreffer
verpassen den er nicht vergisst geben
wir es ihm direkt aufs kind
so viele flugzeuge habe ich in meinem
leben noch nie gesehen ich blickte hinab
auf das zielgebiet und sah nur noch ein
flammenmeer
zu kriegsbeginn hat köln mehr als
750.000 einwohner
im märz 1945 sind es nur noch 40.000
zwei tage nach dem angriff auf köln wird
essen mit der gleichen härte angegriffen
ende juni ist bremen das ziel
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich dass der himmel voller
flugzeuge war das war ein unglaublicher
anblick wie wirkungsvoll das letztlich
war weiß ich nicht
in der nacht vom 24
auf den 25 juli 1943 wird hamburg von
den bis dahin schwersten luftangriffen
der geschichte getroffen
der name der operation ist programm
gomorrha
es ist eine neue dimension der
vernichtung eine fläche von 250.000
quadratmetern steht in flammen
ein feuersturm mit bis zu 1000 grad
celsius wird entfacht
auch wolf biermann hat das inferno in
hamburg erlebt
über uns der weltuntergang und im keller
saßen die leute wie die tiere es war
bald klar dass wir nicht mehr auskommen
weil die glut schon die kellertreppe
herunter koch
es gibt berichte wie das die kampfmoral
der soldaten beeinflusst hat sie sagten
wir kämpfen einen aussichtslosen kampf
an der front und zu hause werden frau
und kinder aus ihren häusern geburt
eine 15 jährige beschreibt das
traumatische erlebnis mutter wickelte
mich in feuchte tücher sie gab mir einen
kuss und sagte lauf
doch kaum ein pilot zweifelt an der
rechtmäßigkeit der mission
wir fragten uns nicht einen moment ob
wir das richtige taten niemals
die luftangriffe auf hamburg zerstören
vier quadratkilometer fläche und
produzieren knapp 43 millionen
kubikmeter trümmer
die bewohner hinterlassen verzweifelte
botschaften auf den trümmern
wo bist du
während des feuersturms in hamburg
sterben mehr als 34.000 menschen
31.600 47 leichen werden geborgen
die royal airforce fliegt
3095 angriffe und meldet 57 verlorene
flugzeuge die us airforce absolviert an
zwei tagen insgesamt
235 tages einsätze und verliert 15
maschinen winston churchill und laut
casey sehen sich filmaufnahmen der
zerbombten deutschen städte an
plötzlich blickte mich an und fragt sind
vier tiere treiben wir es zu weit
die britisch bombing server unit
konstatiert dass die verheerenden
angriffe auf deutsche städte nicht den
gewünschten effekt haben trotzdem werden
sie fortgesetzt nach dem angriff auf
hamburg soll albert speer damals
rüstungsminister gesagt haben noch sechs
solche angriffe und der krieg ist zu
ende
dittli opfers es war unübersehbar für
deutsche zivilisten und
wehrmachtsangehörige dass sich das blatt
im krieg gegen sie wendet einige gäste
[Musik]
japan wird von den flächenbombardements
noch härter getroffen als deutschland
das time magazine schreibt zynisch
wenn man sie richtig anzündet brennen
japanische städte gibt es unter
[Musik]
sobald der krieg in europa beendet ist
wollen die usa all ihre ressourcen gegen
japan einsetzen
vor allem die bi trend hinein super
fortress das langstreckenflugzeug ist
der größte bomba des zweiten weltkriegs
die startbahn und heben 8 305 staaten
und wie vor nicht nur das werk zu
verrichten
hoch am himmel treffen sie sich und
lieben ihre nasen rümpfen kurs auf japan
[Musik]
am 9 märz 1945 werfen
346 band hinein bomber
1665 tonnen bomben über tokio ab
die traditionellen japanischen häuser
die aus holz und papier bestehen werden
von den flammen verschlungen mehr als 41
quadratkilometer tokios brennen
lichterloh
nach offiziellen schätzungen starben
mehr als
130.000 menschen
niemand kennt die genauen opferzahlen
klar ist jedoch es ist der tödlichste
einzel an griff während des zweiten
weltkriegs
[Musik]
ausgelöscht mehr als
250.000 gebäude werden komplett
vernichtet über eine million menschen
verlieren ihr zuhause
[Musik]
majowski takahashi beschreibt tokio nach
dem luftangriff
ein schlachtfeld schlimmer verwüstet als
alles was ich mir je vorstellen konnte
[Musik]
in ganz japan werden 67 städte
bombardiert millionen menschen sind auf
der flucht
im sommer 1945 gehen der bi quentin ein
flotter allmählich die ziele aus
[Musik]
die japanischen städte standen vor dem
kollaps die bevölkerung litt an
krankheiten die durch die grassierende
unterernährung noch verschlimmert worden
mamitu alte und junge drohten zu
verhungern
[Musik]
gibt es für die bomben die auf japan und
deutschland fallen eine moralische
rechtfertigung
noch heute wird diese frage kontrovers
diskutiert und noch heute haben
historiker moralphilosophen und
völkerrechtler keine abschließende
antwort darauf gefunden
fakt ist alle seiten haben bombardiert
alle glaubten die tödlichen luftschläge
würden ihn den sieg bringen
erst als der krieg vorbei ist werden
auch die luftangriffe eingestellt
[Musik]
anfang 1943 beginnt eine reihe von
konferenzen um die weichen für den
weiteren kriegsverlauf und die
nachkriegszeit zu stellen am 14 januar
1943 treffen sich winston churchill und
us präsident roosevelt in casablanca
nach abschluss der gespräche erklärt
roosevelt der presse
frieden wird es erst geben wenn die
kriegs mächte deutschland und japan
komplett ausgeschaltet sind
roosevelt aussage stellt klar dass es
keine friedensverhandlungen mit
deutschland geben soll während die
konferenz karawane nach kairo weiter
zieht kämpfen die alliierten truppen
weiter auf europäischem boden am zehnten
juli beginnen alliierte streitkräfte von
nordafrika kommend mit der invasion
siziliens im rahmen der operation husky
gehen 115.000 britische und kanadische
sowie 66.000 us-soldaten an land nach
einem monat erbitterter kämpfe können
sich 60.000 italienische und 40.000
deutsche soldaten aufs festland retten
anders als die briten 1940 in dünkirchen
gelingt es den deutschen ihr material in
sicherheit zu bringen
sie nehmen mehr als 9000 fahrzeuge sowie
ihr gesamtes arsenal schwerer waffen mit
derweil findet in teheran die nächste
konferenz statt beim treffen der großen
drei ist erstmals auch josef stalin mit
von der partie
eine großartige konferenz die die
vernichtung der deutschen streitkräfte
innerhalb kürzester zeit zum ziel hat
hier sehen die einige der männer die das
gewährleisten
teheran ist doch in anderer hinsicht
interessant denn hier zeigt sich dass
roosevelt bereit war churchill zur seite
zu drängen um stalin zu demonstrieren
dass die amerikaner nicht mit den briten
im gleichschritt marschierten roosevelt
war es wichtig dass spanien das zur
kenntnis nahm
die welt glaubte offenbar dass er stalin
manipulieren könnte tatsächlich war
stalin aber der gewiefte von den dreien
ein meister knallharter diplomatie
rosa welt skizziert seine pläne für
operation overlord die landung der
alliierten in der normandie
stalin ist begeistert
letztlich war es auch ein weiteres
beispiel dafür dass das amerikanische
motto lautete europa zuerst
stalin hatte lange auf eine zweite front
gedrängt churchill dagegen nennt sie die
verdammte zweite front
vermutlich wollte turtle den tag hinaus
zögern an dem er seine eigenen soldaten
gegen die extrem abgehärteten nazi
divisionen ins gefecht schicken musste
1944 wird die verdammte zweite front
realität
doch das jahr beginnt mit einem
entscheidenden feld zog am anderen ende
der welt
[Musik]
in einem land über das die welt nur
wenig weiß